Nachrichten des Tages heute mit niedrige
Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen guten
Abend die sportlichen Highlights später
mit dir Katja sehr gerne schönen guten
Abend hier sind unsere Themen an diesem
Sonntag
Milliarden Poker in der Schweiz die
größte Bank des Landes soll die
angeschlagene Kredit Suisse übernehmen
unterwegs auf besetzten Territorium
russlands Präsident Putin ist
überraschend in die süd-ukrainische
Stadt mariupold gereist
und hoch hinaus am norwegischen Himmel
zum ersten Mal überhaupt müssen sich
Frauen auf einer Skiflugschanze
[Musik]
je nachdem wie es ausgeht könnte sich
ein neues großes banken-beben anbahnen
nach der Pleite von US-Banken taumelt
jetzt das große Schweizer Geldhaus
Credit Suisse das Geschäft mit Banken in
aller Welt verbunden ist entsprechend
hätte ein Zusammenbruch ernsthafte
Folgen für das internationale
Finanzsystem im Raum steht jetzt die
Übernahme durch den lokal Rivalen UBS
unter Hochdruck wird in diesen Minuten
verhandelt Eva Schiller
hektische Krisensitzung ohne Worte noch
schweigt die Schweiz inklusive
nationalbank-präsident Thomas Jordan zu
den Rettungsplänen für die taumelnde
creditsuisse das Land kämpft unter
größtem Zeitdruck um sein angesehenes
Bankenwesen wenn eine Bank dieser
Größenordnung in der Schweiz
zusammenbricht hat das für den
Finanzplatz Schweiz
ganz unvorstellbare Auswirkungen das
wird man in der Schweiz auf keinen Fall
riskieren wollen dieser Druck zeigt
Wirkung Medienberichten zufolge ist die
UBS widerwillig bereit die Kredit Suisse
für mehr als zwei Milliarden Dollar zu
kaufen letzten Freitag war sie noch über
sieben Milliarden wert eine neue
Schweizer mega-bank würde entstehen
ich habe eine Grundregel im Banking
heutzutage ist dass man keine Großfusion
mehr macht dass man keine andere Bank
übernimmt von der man nicht weiß welche
Risiken Sie denn mitbringt aber da sind
kaum Alternativen letzte Woche rauschte
der Aktienkurs der Credit Suisse in den
Keller die Kunden zogen ihr Kapital ab
in Milliardenhöhe da stehen zehntausende
Arbeitsplätze auf dem Spiel und dann ist
da weltweit die Sorge vor dem
ansteckungseffekt
ist ein absolutes Desaster für den
Finanzplatz Schweiz für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Schweiz aber es ist
für das gesamte internationale
Bankensystem ein absolut beherrschbarer
Vorfall
bevor die Börsen morgen wieder öffnen
will die Schweiz eine Lösung verkünden
die Regierung hat für den Abend eine
Pressekonferenz anberaumt wohl auch um
die internationale Finanzwelt zu
beruhigen
ja und so eben hören wir dass die
Pressekonferenz der Regierung gleich um
19 Uhr beginnen soll zum Ukraine Krieg
der auch ein Krieg der Bilder und
Inszenierungen ist das russische
russische Staatsfernsehen
veröffentlichte heute Material von
Präsident Putin das ist so noch nicht
gegeben hat zum ersten Mal seit dem
Angriff besuchte er die besetzten
Gebiete etwa Mario Paul die Hafenstadt
die im vergangenen früher nach heftigen
Kämpfen schwer zerstört wurde Nina
niederrichtet
ein Bericht des russischen
Staatsfernsehen Vladimir Putin sei in
der Nacht in Mario voll gelandet im
Schutz der Dunkelheit lässt er sich die
Stadt zeigen die russische Truppen vor
einem Jahr in Schutt und Asche gelegt
haben
diese Gegend ist schon wieder gut
aufgebaut da sind sogar Spielplätze ja
genau Spielplätze
alles ist sorgfältig orchestriert
begleitet von Kreml treuen Medien
produziert Putin gezielt die Bilder die
die Welt sehen soll spricht mit
Passanten die wie zufällig dazukommen
lässt sich Bilder vom zerstörten Theater
zeigen
das Theater aus es wurde schon umgebaut
wir stellen die erste Show für den 15
April auf die Beine
das Theater in mario-poll war Schauplatz
einer der schlimmsten Verbrechen dieses
Krieges Ukrainer hatten dort Schutz
gesucht bei einem russischen Luftangriff
wurden hunderte getötet die Stadt im
Donbass erlebte wochenlang viel Leid und
Zerstörung gut ein Jahr später nun
Putins besucht
eine Antwort auf die in der Gesellschaft
verwurzelte Vorstellung von Putin als
Bunker Opa der nirgendwo hingeht in
einem Bunker sitzt und vor allem Angst
hat und zweitens ist es eine Antwort auf
Präsident selenskis Reisen an die Front
und US-Präsident beidens Besuch in Kiew
alles unter Kontrolle auch das sollen
wohl die Bilder zeigen von der
inszenierten bei Nacht
die Balkanstaaten Serien und Kosovo sind
verfeindet und haben sich bei
Verhandlungen jetzt wohl angenäht wie
sehr darüber gab es nach einem Treffen
vergangene Nacht unterschiedliche
Ansichten wir haben einen Deal sagte der
EU-Außenbeauftragte Borell ich habe
heute nichts unterschrieben der
serbische Präsident Vucic 12 Stunden
lang hatten beide Seiten unter
Vermittlung von Borell verhandelt
Serbien erkennt die Unabhängigkeit des
Kosovo nicht an beide wollen aber in die
EU
nach Israel dort reißen die Proteste
gegen die geplante Justizreform der
Regierung nicht ab wieder sind gestern
in Tel Aviv und anderen Städten 10.000
Menschen auf die Straßen gegangen um zu
demonstrieren den 11 Samstag in Folge
die Regierung unter Ministerpräsident
Netanjahu will die Befugnisse des
höchsten Gerichts begrenzen kritiker
befürchten die Aufhebung der
Gewaltenteilung und sehen die Demokratie
in Gefahr
bei einem schweren Erdbeben in der
Grenzregion zwischen Ecuador und Peru
sind mindestens 15 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen hunderte weitere wurden
verletzt das Leben hat eine Stärke von
6,8 es verursachte besonders in ecodoss
steht nahe der Pazifikküste schwere
Gebäudeschäden zerstört wurden vor allem
ältere instabile Häuser in
ärmeren Wohngegenden
mit einem ökumenischen Gottesdienst
wurde heute in Hamburg an die Opfer des
hamburg-laufs bei den Zeugen Jehovas vor
anderthalb Wochen erinnert man wolle
einen Raum zum Trauern und Trost spenden
so die Initiatoren die Zeugen Jehovas
nahmen an der Trauerfeier nicht teil
würdigten sie aber als Zeichen der
Anteilnahme ein bewaffneter Mann hat den
Hamburg sieben Menschen und sich selbst
getötet
die Erde erwärmt sich noch schneller als
befürchtet und die bislang ergriffenen
Maßnahmen dagegen reichen bei weitem
nicht aus das sind die beiden
Kernaussagen im neuen Bericht des
Weltklimarates der morgen veröffentlicht
wird ablesen lässt sich dieser
Wettertrend auch am deutschen Winter
einmal mehr war er deutlich zu warm aber
immerhin im europäischen Vergleich nicht
ganz so trocken Julia Schröter
Andreas kattler ist Landwirt in Essingen
in der Südpfalz sein winterhartweizen
wächst gerade ganz gut dank des Regens
der letzten Wochen insgesamt aber hätte
es etwas mehr sein dürfen
wir sind nun mal so weit zufrieden nur
das trockene Jahr vom letzten Jahr
kann der Niederschlag das was man jetzt
haben nicht ausgleichen besonders
trocken war der Februar da viel gar kein
Regen das war eine Situation wie in der
Wüste wenn sie mit der Ecke gefahren
sind dann hat sie dann gestaubt sie
haben keinen Traktor mehr gesehen vielen
werden von diesem Winter vor allem weiße
schneebänder in grüner Landschaft im
Gedächtnis bleiben die Schneeschmelze
fällt dadurch gering aus und so gleicht
mancher Gebirgsbach einer Steinwüste
auch im Rhein zeigen sich schon jetzt
große Sandbänke das kann ja durchaus
sein dass ein Winter mal kühler ist und
dann gibt es aber auch wieder wärmere
und der Trend ist eher zu wärmeren
Wintern also man sieht hier durchaus die
Erhitzung in Deutschland die sich weiter
fortsetzt eben auch im Winter
Tiefstwert waren am 18.12 - 19,3 Grad im
Landkreis Bayreuth kaum zwei Wochen
später an Silvester ein extrem in die
andere Richtung plus 20,8 Grad in
Oberbayern wärmer war der Jahreswechsel
nie
bei den Sonnenstunden war der Winter
voll im Durchschnitt trotzdem der
Frühling darf jetzt kommen
naja jedenfalls gibt es noch ordentlich
Schnee in Schweden und dort waren die
Deutschen in der langlaufstaffel
erfolgreich katja
hat das deutsche Team bestehend aus zwei
Frauen und zwei Männern für das erste
deutsche Staffel Podest im Weltcup seit
über sechs Jahren gesorgt das Quartett
landete auf Platz drei
Katharina Hennig Victoria Karl an Jan
Sossau und Albert Kuchler gelingt über
die 4 x 5 km eine Überraschung vor dem
letzten Wechsel Deutschland noch fünfter
doch dann die starke Schlussläuferin
Victoria Karl in der Loipe auf den
letzten Metern sicher die 27-Jährige den
deutschen Quartett Rang 3 etwas mehr als
6 Sekunden schneller die siegreichen
Schweden Norwegen auf Platz 2
Deutschlands Biathleten blieben im
letzten Saison Rennen in Oslo ohne
Podestplatz und der Bundestrainer Mark
Kirchner tritt zurück nach 13 Jahren
Nachfolger werden der bisherige
Co-Trainer Uwe lepads und der ehemalige
Skilangläufer Jens Hilbrich in der
Fußball-Bundesliga hat Union Berlin im
ersten Sonntagsspiel 2:0 gegen Eintracht
Frankfurt gewonnen ist dadurch auf Platz
drei Täter der Tabelle und noch zu einer
Premiere erstmals sind auch die Frauen
skigeflogen beim Weltcup in Vikas und
Norwegen reicht es allerdings für
Deutschlands Nummer eins Katharina
Althaus knapp nicht für einen
Podestplatz
Katharina Althaus verpasst den
wickersund die 200 Meter-Marke weiß aber
um die historische Bedeutung des ersten
Frauen schief Fliegens wir haben einfach
Geschichte geschrieben ich glaube
es passiert halt nicht alle Tage
194 und 190 Meter Platz 4 für die
siebenmalige Weltmeisterin die ihre
Karriere fortsetzen will die Slowenien
Emma clean Netz gewinnt und stellt einen
Weltrekord auf 226 Meter so weit ist
noch keine Frau geflogen bei den Männern
der Österreicher Stefan Kraft ganz oben
gerade aus Norwegen sichert sich mit dem
zweiten Platz die Rohr Gesamtwertung
bester Deutscher Andreas Wellinger 13
6 m hat man Zeit zum Nachdenken das ist
dann fliegen danke Katja wir schauen auf
fix aufs Wetter morgen anfangs im
südostenschauer am Nachmittag regnet es
im Norden leicht sonst trocken mit der
meisten Sonne im Südwesten 11 bis 17
Grad an den Küsten ist es kühler die
kommenden Tage werden wechsaft bei meist
10 bis 19 Grad um 21:45 Uhr gibt's das
heute journal mit Marie das lomka
schönen Dank fürs zuschauen wir sehen
uns morgen wieder und geben jetzt direkt
in die Hauptstadt zu Berlin direkt und
sharko runterladen energy